Greeks woke to another day filled with
uncertainty for their future at this
newsstand headlines read Judgment Day
and the package deal for remaining in
the euro but members of parliament were
optimistic as they headed into morning
meetings with Prime Minister Alexis
tsipras we will give authorization
Parliament is very well informed
everything will go well but by the look
of it Greek ministers met throughout the
day and night yesterday to hammer out
this new proposal now Prime Minister
Alexis tsipras has to convince his own
party to accept some of the increased
austerity measures they had fought to
avoid like pension cuts some Greeks hope
that won't happen if this is Europe then
we don't want this you first of all we
are the Europe Greece is Europe we teach
them and now wake up back to do what are
you doing in Athens make people slaves
by the money outside of Parliament banks
remain closed the Greek people continue
their long wait for a breakthrough as
tensions particularly among pensioners
are on the rise